there's gotta be at least one dog
watching the stream right now
so the one dog out there
woof woof
okay i'm getting sidetracked already
i want to explain what happened last
night
because last night
i was in the middle of like a serious
game
and then i had to like rush away
and
do something
because like somehow the topic of domain
names came up
and
there is like an offhand comment to buy
staffordgambit.com
and i checked it was available
but
i can't mention i'm about to buy
stafford gambit.com
[Music]
uh
because then someone might beat me to it
so
during the game last night i bought
staffordgambit.com
and now if you go to staffordgamma.com
i just set it up to redirect to the
um
my merch site so
now i have two very valuable domain
names
staffordgamma.com and oh no my queen dot
com
along with ironrose.com
also big thanks to the person who sent
me this mug
it's first time using this mug on stream
i arrived the other day it's probably my
biggest mug
even bigger than
this other mug i was sent
which says
something about things being big in
dallas
okay here we go
this is bullet chess
i'll be playing someone next to me
probably
oh let's turn off pentatonic
because sometimes it slows me down
hello eric hello steven gray welcome
back
i have the bishop hair a little bit less
space trying to make do
do i want to trade
maybe i do maybe i don't
i don't know what to do here
i'm stuck
i need this idea
really no time for deliberation and
bullets
don't hurt me
mmm getting hurt
oh no my queen
[Music]
oh no my rook
okay not my proudest start i'll resign
what what what did i do wrong
maybe it's already losing already losing
here
why play the good game
yeah i'm just losing here
i had to play apparently d6
uh g6 earlier yeah d6 okay
back to tournaments
hurried at 55.
that's surprisingly low
i hope
i'm okay
uh no berserking i just want to win a
game
uh what's the line here i think it's
this
did you exercise earlier
um
[Music]
i was cleaning cleaning my place
that was some form of exercise
i'm trying to exercise my queen
but i was saying uh on yesterday's
stream
i wanna
i wanna do like a workout stream
i think this is okay
oh no white's queen okay
i feel bad napa is working back but i
just wanted to win a game
oh yeah so i'm i'm playing the title
arena i'm not doing viewer challenges
now
uh if you want a chance to play me
uh link is now in the chat
and
yeah the goal is to have some fun games
um i know it's faster pace than usual
i'll still try and provide some tidbits
of instructed value
uh here and there
what does that sound
i had another tab open
okay i'm playing a delayed crab
just trying to pinch my opponent
id f3
maybe castling
and doing some weird maneuvering maybe
at some point
never mind
that's a good move
am i losing a piece i might be losing a
piece here
i'm also losing a lot of time
a great situation
no
ah
i was
i was closer actually if my king were
here and my pawn couldn't move
there's some stalemate idea tricks but
oh no my prime sub what to do oh yes
your prime sub thank you jalam
it's soothing the pain with something
with prime hey it's talkie talkies use
this to buy puffin stuffed slash toy in
iceland oh do they sell puffin toys in
iceland
or can i buy a real puffin
probably not
not sure how i feel about the delayed
crab
yeah i should have had a more um
prompt crab
maybe
here we have half a crab
just have to complete the other half
oh i deserved
i deserved
okay
down the pawn
don't hurt me
gotta unleash the pre-moves
okay
ah
oh i got a little bit distracted there
i if i berserk i should really pay
attention that i was hurting
if you find a real puffin it could be
hard to take the puffin on the airplane
back home
yeah maybe i'll like just rent a puffin
wait what oh i pressed f
that's my inner
impulse is taking over
okay sapphire gamba time
not the best start to a tournament but
uh
i'll try and recover
again this is just a warm
knight g5
hitting this pawn
oh no
this is going terribly wrong
i'm just down oh no no no no no no no no
what am i supposed to do in this opening
i know it's objectively not good for
black
knight g5 must move
ah queen e2 is um yeah most people don't
play queen e2
but white knew what to do
okay i have to be careful knight d5 is a
better move
hey it's google boosh
okay i've i've won
one out of five games
could be
better hard for it to be much worse
okay this time i'll pay attention i'm
berserking
i'll pre-move e5
uh
go for this
like early g5
okay i like when
opponents give me free gifts
do i try and set up castling queenside
with meat
uh
it might be difficult
i'll just take all the pawns
uh okay castle queen sign on move 25
oh is there g5
mate i didn't see it
okay
and g5 was made in two
okay 364.
um
no berserking
let's try and stay focused let's um i'll
try and build a streak
tournaments like this can be very
streaky
momentum is important
castle queenside probably next
i'm going for the quick breakdown on the
king side
this idea
yeah the queen just wants to
invade the dark squares
i'm now threatening this
hey it's someone buying merch someone
purchased
hoodie for 44.90
uh
i do appreciate that happy four months
dad x
dad x
is that the father of spacex
uh where's my win
okay this looks good enough
hey eric thanks for all the content i
hope great things happen to you buddy oh
great things are about to happen
i'm about to get a pawn diamond
hey i got another rosen trophy look at
my beautiful pond diamond
it's so gorgeous
uh what do i do here
there we go
sometimes you have to sacrifice a
diamond to
survive
okay oh and i got a pawn checkmate
do i get two rosen trophies for one game
pawn diamond and rosen checkmate
upping my rosin score let's go
yeah again we have the rosen score
command
you can also go to just
rosenscore.com
and
see how many rows and trophies you have
opponent resigns okay they probably saw
my previous game
and were too terrified
okay
i'll deserve back
someone else getting merch someone
purchased cousteau hoodie for 46.45
and donated three dollars oh that's kind
thanks so much
what am i doing here
that
okay let's go
hey top hundred
so i'm on the streak now
top 80.
berserk again
let's go for one of these
doh my knight
ah
oh it's not falling for it
i'll still try and be aggressive here
idea queen h4
i'm threatening the pawn with the bishop
i'm getting the queen
preventing queen g3
there's queen f4
and your queen f3
queen g2 and then rook comes in
[Music]
there we go okay that was nice
if the rook were to block i'd go the
other
way okay
so trying to make up for the rocky start
what pgn viewer is best for noobs like
me
uh leech us we just study is amazing and
it's completely free
you can import pgns organize things
wow opponent didn't even give me time to
berserk back
to e4
play rook b1
this pawn is defended
okay that was pleasant
fantastic power okay 16th place this is
a prize tournament
top three finishers win money
okay playing wukong
competition will get a little bit
tougher
[Music]
what is going on here
i mean visually it looks pretty good
acoustically it sounds good
[Music]
okay that was nice
my first time beating a high-rated
player this tournament
playing chess player
okay i'll repeat the same line
i got crushed in this earlier
this is my time for redemption okay g3
walks into a trap
let's go
nice to have a quick win
so i'm in fourth place
um i think this is okay
that's really risky though
foreign
let's go
oh no my heart rate
okay
let's
go nice win versus strong opponent thank
you
thank you stephen gray
hey it's gotham what's up gotham
i'm so
flustered by gotham's raid my heart rate
is 152.
shout out to levy
thanks to at 95 horatio for my sub gift
thank you 95 horatio
yeah if you're just joining i'm uh
i'm playing in this uh titled warm-up
tournament
i'm in fourth place
despite losing my first 4 out of 5 games
bishop e7
it's about to blunder everything there
it's a very difficult position here
play b5
spending too much time
don't hurt me
don't hurt me
oh
i got hurt
i missed queen of seven that's a
difficult position
with the time situation
okay uh i'm still top ten
how am i playing someone rated 2 000 in
fourth place
no i'm okay
it's still probably pretty good
yeah this player is very underrated
let's play this move
i am getting completely outplayed
let's still might win this
nice
okay
this this tournament so far is a workout
it's like comparable to
lifting or running or
light jogging
also things for subbing
amari ge
okay this is some opening prop
um
asics i'm not so familiar with
stafford gambit rules
oh man
um
oh tactics
lost some time there but
position looks pretty good
tricky tricky
um
oh it's tilting i was very tilted it was
a good position too
what to do
now i'm playing rob i think rob likes to
play london or no
play one of these
oh what is this line
we got the sign
c6
i don't know what i'm doing here g5
i have no idea what i'm doing here
let's just do things
i want to checkmate
oh g2 is defended
that's unfortunate
all right now there's some hope still
i don't know how i have hope here if i
have hope
hello eric good luck today
thank you i'm gonna need it here
get ready for it get ready for it
we all knew it was coming
let's
go let's go
oh i'm so happy
that's another another trophy for the
tournament
okay
grand master hangs upon
uh hangs a knight no
let's play this move
so it takes i never mind
eric have you ever tried a tea called
milky oolong tea yeah it's a tea from
fuji in china where the oolong leaves
are steamed over milk
it's my favorite tea and if you've never
tried it i might send you some it's
awesome uh yeah we have a mail command
if you want to send me
tea
let's not hang a queen
what
star
what's going on here
don't hurt me
um
let's go let's go
okay
still hovering around top ten
leader has 64 points
playing darkest phoenix
and not berserking
not bizarre
i'm holding true to my word
or am i multiple words
i was the same opening as a previous
game too
previous game my opponent took with pawn
but very similar ideas
every night
free queen
let's go
hmm i blender
i think i blundered but
white didn't punish me
really
um
i wanted to set up the trap again oh oh
that was such a um
it was a good game too
i fended off the attack and i was up at
peace but
time eyes was difficult
okay opponent falls for a basic drop
this trap happens so often in bullets do
you watch formula one i don't
i've heard of it though
hm
c4
c4 is interesting
it doesn't really solve the problems
still threatening takes in check
this thing is pinned
before
connect four
oops
oops
okay opponent mrs bishop h5
everything in life is free
okay
top 20 still
so trying to rebuild a streak
still have a lot of tea left for the
stream
interesting
i feel like i'm getting smushed
but thankfully we're trading a bit
yeah these pawns are targets
the time is quite pleasant this game
keep leaving tension
i think this is okay
i could have taken on g6 first
oh funny mate coming
funny mates okay
a very typical mating pattern in those
sort of end games
okay apologies i don't have so much
time to interact with chat but i hope
people are doing well today
uh welcome to all the new viewers and
returning viewers thank you graph cs
who subbed
uh okay let's play more chess
i just blundered c6 but uh
white's being kind
this pawn is a bit tender i could have
taken it right away actually
um
preventing rook b1
maybe you should not have allowed that
a weird position here
i don't mind it though
let's
check was sneaky but
not sneaky enough
okay
um yeah hovering around 10.
and blunder i think i blundered
what do i do here b4
bishop d2
weird position
i'm not supposed to allow this but
i guess it's still okay
good move
okay momentum is shifting
you
i feel a little bit dirty there but
that's why time is important
okay
hey number 10.
we're not yet at the halfway point
playing this player again
hmm
uh
just a little bit too slow there what to
do
okay
12th place
um not a great opening
but it's something
i can work with this
um
at unity five
hmm
f6 was really ugly but
what to do
get ready for it get ready get ready yes
number two this stream
okay
let's go
playing grandmaster arm
rated above three thousand
an opening
doh
the knight is trapped
oh i got tricked
wow i got tricked
how do you treat me
hmm
never resign when you have nights
i just got mated what i just got mated i
was kind of sad
oh
that's berserk
oh this person
this is like the underrated player
i played earlier
why not berserk
um
what should i do
i don't know how that player is rated 2
000
uh
what to do okay playing fantastic power
i played earlier
[Music]
like to keep things tense
okay
it's pleasant having a time advantage
like that
uh still top 20
meter has a hundred wow
playing green knight who's in second
place
we just have an advanced variation
we do
[Music]
interesting line
i should have played 96 first
it's still interesting
some compensation here
not easy to find the move for black
now the king is a bit stuck
i'm guaranteed some nasty discoveries
speaking of nasty
that was a nice game
okay
as the power of double check
the king would have to move
running two things
okay this looks quite good now
yeah this is uh the delayed reverse crab
don't mess with my crab
as night is trapped
if takes was made otherwise i'm
i was threatening to promote with a rook
with double rook checkmate
okay uh 15th place
we're past the halfway
point reverse london
got some fork
so up a full rook
okay
too many options there but
resigning was nice
another strong player
i got tricked
i guess i got tricked
one
mmm
ah
okay oh that was unfortunate
can't allow queen a5 in that line
well played
okay
eleventh place
try and stay focused here
yeah this is already a pleasant line
let's go okay
that was a nice game this was a
very typical london style game
i was following a lot of ideas in my
london course
with the queen side tactics
okay
um 71 points
um
i don't know the line here
i'll just make something up
wow
how bad is this
don't hurt me
don't hurt me
my king is weirdly developed
i had to prevent b4
here we simplify oh i'm maybe winning
the rook actually
look here i have this move you've
succeeded in activating the king yeah
it's paying off too
let's go
i'm just winning the rook
now do i deactivate my king
what is this
and white's activated his king too
uh
checkmate
oh that's not meat where's my mates
free rook
okay there's my needs
let's go
trying to rebuild a streak
same opponent as earlier
they don't they're too scared to develop
lightweight bishop this time
still go for some punishment
oh no box rook
[Music]
lock wasn't expecting queenie too
okay top ten again
thank you jingot
oh wait what
straw
opponent left the game
opponent probably left the planet
okay
oh they tried to dirty pre-move trick me
but i was expecting them to take the
night so didn't really work
[Music]
i lose back never mind
um
some upper pawn here
okay i love e5 for a moment but
i didn't play it
a little bit low on space
a knight's pin to the rook
d4 is a nice quarter for the bishop
and probably shouldn't have done that
most meaning though
threatening this move
now it's writing made in one
a funny position
usually there's another queen on g3
controlling h2
okay seventh place
yeah third is still kinda far away but
just take it one game at a time
hey thank you islamic noob
welcome back appreciate the gifted subs
mom's spaghett
[Music]
spaghetti
this
let's go
thank you kevin kariki
and swagness carlson appreciate that
okay sixth place
i'm in trouble
[Music]
yeah
um
yeah
too much trouble
ah
okay still not bad
lost my streak but
in good standing
thank you devil for the two months
weird opening thing
okay
g4 was
the move to make bishop e4 very strong
okay back on track
oh no my win quack quack
quack quack
wait what
what just happened
did i make a weird pre-move
wait
what just happened
after the game i'll have to investigate
[Music]
queen is pretty much stuck
ah well played
oh wait wait uh
real quick i think i know what happened
i got confused about the ompassant
right
join
yeah i was expecting this so i pre-moved
bishop takes c4 but on passant
that was so bad unfortunately
uh what to do
life goes on
it's alpha gamma time
should be really careful here
i also be careful too
turning this now
yeah that's a funny meat
okay some nice geometry of that game
oh it's painful
that should have been a pretty
straightforward win to what to do
[Music]
just have to move on seventh place
oh white was tricky that game
this is what i need
let's go six move win
it's not even a dirty line like queen f3
is uh his theory
emerging theory
playing rob again
against a
2900
too
yeah
winning in six moves
okay let's have some
fun oh no my queen
oh why does that move
wait for it wait for it wait for it
oh he's not taking the rook
oh
i think i tricked him in the previous
game so now he knows uh
it'd be funny if he fell for it twice
he didn't even give me the hope of
setting up the stalemate trap
ah
it was a cool game too i think i was
better even after i lost the queen but
it's a very tricky position
uh
yeah we'll play
um
missing tactics
it's still interesting though nights are
going to be
tricky hopefully
i'm in trouble though
still interesting
um
okay
it was quicker to get mated than resign
there
[Music]
okay so top ten
it's hard to rebuild a streak when i'm
playing so many wrong players
this one again
b3
[Music]
never resign
keep fighting eric
i'm fighting i'm fighting
oh my queen
i'm still fighting
i'm resigning yeah
what to do
oh there's a good position gee
just dropped a queen for nothing
okay playing person in first place
oh i know that they oh they don't know
what to do
i think queen d6 queen d7
it's getting messy
young children close your eyes what is
this position
oh no my queen
oh no my queen
if takes it's meat though so that was
kind of a cool
idea
okay
i beat the leader
i had this earlier
not quite the same
thing um
look at this move
i almost blundered me too
okay
yeah it was easy flying
as long as i didn't get mated
okay
so on the streak again
see if i can keep it up
a lot of stafford decliners here
you were having all the fun last game
regardless
it's true
that's true
yes let's go let's go
oh
it wasn't easy to set up either
required a lot of luck
how many so many traps this tournament
earning my trophies
okay
what is this
what is this
gg
okay back on the streak
that's a rose and trap hat trick
yeah yeah that's true
i just want a pawn diamond
um
let's go
yeah i haven't been searched at all this
tournament i don't think
except that one game
i get such underrated
[Music]
2000 i had this line earlier
i like what i did earlier just cast on
queenside
it's risky but
why not
[Music]
i'm in big trouble
please stop hurting me
please
let's go okay i don't know how i
survived that
i was getting absolutely demolished
let's go
i've had this line a few times already
today
opponent was too focused on his own
attack yeah
chess is a two-sided game
very risky
i'm regretting my life decisions
wow get it appreciate you
i appreciate you too
such a bad position
okay what to do
oh that kind of fell apart
yeah i guess i shouldn't take on e5 in
these lines
okay
um
gotta try and refocus
maybe i can catch sharky croc
uh there's a sign
eric's on a streaming hot streak
hey d lafayette
welcome back
it's actually not a great opening but
i'm trying to
play the position
hmm
oh no that was a bad move
don't come in my crib
this is my crib
let's go dirty flag
okay
interesting
terrifying position
well played
ah
too much pressure there what to do
okay we're nearing the end
i'll try and finish strong
playing rob again
oh no i made a mess out of this
i'm just losing
okay
well played
i got nothing on the f file and y got
everything on the a file
okay deep breath
still a decent result overall
i should take a break at some point
um
but still
i still want to try and end on a happy
note
it's upon diamond
that earns me another rosen
[Music]
i don't know if it was worth achieving
upon diamond
stop hurting me
foreign
yes
let's go
i had five seconds left two to twelve
seconds
that's the fourth stalemate trick of the
stream
that's why you never resign children
and adults
okay i want to break back into the top
10
playing 3000 rated player
really
you
final final position was a draw somehow
i don't know how i tricked him
wow
[Music]
just not enough time
okay
playing slipknot
i should really take a break uh
let's play this line
um
queen e4
weird move but i'm controlling the
center
oh funny line
oh no my queen
huh
does that work queen of seven
i spent way too long there
oh gosh
i have to convert this position
this
that's sad
i should have i i spent too long looking
for the funny mate
oh where is my funny mate i wanted to
play queen f7 and finish the game in
style
i mean everything was winning but
is there force mate it just took way too
long there
as some force mate
um
that's slightly disappointing
uh i'll play a few more then i'll take a
break
it's walrus time
probably not a good sign that i'm
playing the walrus
but it's kind of paying off
this is this
[Music]
line queen h8 ideas
king d2
what is this game
ah it's a pork
the pin fork
this is such a funny game
king b3 only moved to defend the pawn
a4
white's king going for a walk
where's my meat
am i not mating
what is this game
the king is so slippery
yeah i finally caught the king
oh such a funny game
wow
i'm not taking a break because i i feel
motivated to finish top ten
there's only three minutes left so
there will be a small break between
tylerina
and this tournament
most elusive king in a while
yeah
i prefer my king's non-elusive
also with cream and sugar
i'm losing a pawn
[Music]
but the knight is fee encountered in my
territory so
maybe there's some compensation
okay i went back upon lose this pawn
or that pawn but win this pawn
what's going on
i can't quite take that
really
top
[Music]
so much rage
okay final game berserk
opponents work back
oh my queen
i mean i don't have any way to save the
queen
at least i have a tetris piece
look at my pawns
they're so pretty
let's go
let's go
oh
my queen was reborn
look at these pawns the ponds
existed in so many different forms of
tetris pieces
we had the t shape the sideways t
the whatever you call this thing
this thing is not even a tetris piece it
should be
okay uh
well i
i can take a small break i guess